Fire Emblem fates revelation offers the
most rewarding story of all three Fire
Emblem fates games
it sets you down a path where you choose
to side with neither your adopted
siblings nor your birth family and
instead seek to unite everyone to your
cause this version has the most
characters available which means more
options for romance as well as battle
tactics combat is still a slow march of
picking and choosing who to engage and
when to hang back her revelation changes
things up with a wide variety of maps
these maps require you to interact with
the environment in ways that alter the
landscape or sometimes they block
everything out altogether making you
seek around in the dark to hunt for your
enemy it's a heightened sperm it's
sister games but it's also the one with
the most epic ending there's a lot of
emotion here but you should definitely
play conquest or birth rate before you
dig in for context in the end Fire
Emblem fates revelation is a beautiful
mix of meaningful gameplay and a
passionate story
you